in November and the rebellion quit the
government over tourism they suppress it
deal and in her resignation letter she
raised concerns about the Irish backstop
and also the fishing industry and we're
pleased to say that she joins us there
now thank you very much for being with
us so has a Christmas break made you
change your mind I'm afraid it hasn't no
there's been no change to the withdrawal
agreement documentation or indeed the
political decoration documentation so my
view still stands at the moment it just
isn't something that has a break fear
and someone who believes that we must
respect the will of the people through
that referendum ordered that we were
given this doesn't do that it someone
who's quite plugged into uni the
conservative benches do you have any
indication that people are changing
their minds no not really it's been
really interesting actually we've all
you know chat over Christmas and you
know keep trying to get ahead and we
know we all of us want to leave on the
28th March with with a deal or the you
know the framework for sorting out the
logistics of a transition period if we
possibly can so you know deal is not
something you'd like to see well I'd
rather not but I'm also very focused on
making sure that preparedness is
actually in place that's been one of the
challenges I've been pushing the prime
minister for a while now both publicly
and privately say are you sure that
everything's in place because the
challenge I get coming back from my
constituents bit the fishing community
as you mentioned the farmer community
small businesses my constituency has no
you know if you know big check your Land
Rover companies it has lots of small
businesses some of whom trade with the
EU is the question is is it ready and
they're saying to me well we don't know
you don't know it's all I know so no
deals just really scary but actually you
know and as some of the civil service
articles written recently have shown the
civil service you know best in the world
ours
is preparing I think the challenge we've
got is that Prime Minister has been slow
to make sure that businesses know to try
and reduce that fear and anxiety knowing
that much like the millennium bug crisis
you probably were you know old enough to
remember but I do the world was going to
end everywhere but the reality is that
you know the civil service is prepared
and all those all that can be put in
place will be and businesses need to
know that so I think that's a critical
part of once we get through this week's
you know noise and fireworks
to actually make sure that businesses do
know what's what if they are having a
new relationships now and at the same
time though you're somebody who backed
brexit we just heard from Chris Grayling
the transport secretary who made the
point that if you don't back the Prime
Minister's deal then there is a concern
among many people who supported leave
the brakes it might not happen or it
will be much much softer than you would
like it to be I mean is that is that not
something that you're concerned about so
the reality is that the statute in place
at the moment is to leave on the 29th of
March either with an agreed deal which
is what the Prime Minister has been
negotiating or if one can't be reached
by then on a No Deal basis and then we
continue the conversation afterwards but
we will have stepped away from all those
new connections there's a lot in the
withdrawal agreement that's fine it's
it's like a basket of all the legacy
stuff wrapped up in one so it's much
easier if we can do it you know you know
you know one big clue that there's some
of it's just not acceptable because it
won't deliver brexit but at the same
time that you knew that if you look at
the papers today there's lots of stories
there in the Sunday Times for example
amongst others about MPs who are
absolutely opposed to the idea of a no
deal brexit talking about bringing a new
legislation to stop it happening well
you know that is that is a great
challenge and some of the you know the
activity we've seen this week in
Parliament with you know trying to so
dramatically change how Parliament works
that everything becomes completely
unstable is indeed as the promises
herself you know into unprecedented and
unchartered territory but that must not
stop us from remembering that we we gave
the people a referendum now it's a
fairly blunt tool don't think any of us
would disagree with that but having done
so if we don't respect the results that
they sent back to us which is an order
it's not a nice idea for us to now
continue to discuss it was a very clear
order we must make sure that we actually
leave the EU and the withdrawal
agreement as it stands will not do that
because of the Irish backstop so that
needs to be something that Prime
Minister goes back to the EU and says
I'm afraid you know Parliament says this
isn't this isn't acceptable this is the
area of concern please can we fix it
we've got you know nearly three months
to do that for them to them to decide
this isn't for the Prime Minister it's
not under her control I think that's the
frustration it's all been kind of dumped
on her head actually the EU have to
decide whether they are okay with a No
Deal position on this Wrentham are
or whether they would rather make some
amendments now so that that bulk of the
resort which is absolutely fine can be
put through okay and I'm interested to
talk to you a little bit about the
future of the Conservative Party as well
because it's been a really bruising
couple of years because it has been
fighting like cats and dogs there to be
blunt you've spoken before about worries
about young voters being switched off
from the Conservatives and even saying
that your own son might not vote for you
well no one ever let me finish that
sense and then are you still worried
that he might not thank you I think I
think probably he would he can now vote
the problem the time was he was he was a
few days off being able to vote in the
2017 election my finish that sentence
was because I probably not right wing
enough for him oh of course that wasn't
that wasn't chosen but it's a really
it's a really much much like there are
extraordinary number of incredibly
focused young people interesting
politics I think the challenge they've
had is to try to get to grips they but
they're arriving into politics at this
monumental point and at this point where
we're using a tool that is you know use
very very rarely perhaps just as well
the referendum and trying to understand
what it means so we've if having used a
referendum which is a direct order
rather than normal politics which is you
elect your MP and then you let them you
know make their judgement and if you
don't like the way they make judgments
you chuck them out the next time around
the reference something else so they're
they're caught in this trying to
understand what normal politics might
look like alongside this dramatic and in
the Conservative Party it sound does not
look good at the minute does it well I
think then the day I think all parties
are on a state of huge black the Labour
Party is equally you know split in the
way you know it's trying to find how it
goes forward with a you know a very hard
left call sitting on the front bench and
all you know those who have been if you
like the wisdom and the experience of
the Labour Party for the last thirty
years sitting behind them on the back
benches I think that's in both cases and
maybe it reflects you know the fact that
this is as having a referendum generates
huge political energy and we must make
sure that we harness it carefully and
that it goes forwards so that our
country can do as well as it can okay
thank you very much